let's get to hearing from some people in
the audience I can't think of anybody
more important than the folks who make
this show possible through their
viewership and listenership we take
calls on Fridays at join Pac-Man
davidpackman.com Discord rather and you
can join the Discord that way let's
start today
um with oh I don't know it's so hard to
say how about
Joe from Massachusetts Joe from
Massachusetts welcome let's all hope for
no technical trouble and that we have an
auspicious start today
how do I sound David you sound good what
do you have like a creaky door there
oh that's my chair leaning back I'm my
bad oh no problem maybe some dry lube
would would deal with that noise maybe
it would I'm just gonna stick it up
oh boy now you're starting to cut in and
out Joe let's hope we can get a question
here
I'm just so bad okay now I heard that
okay
Mike's about um George Anthony devalder
Santos yes the third Nobel Peace Prize
winner
um
first contributions to nuclear fission
um so my quick disclaimer right before I
get to the question is that he should
resign because his voters voted for
somebody else basically absolutely
but uh my question is I want your take
would it actually be beneficial to the
left
if he stayed on like each week a new a
new lie a new Scandal and more infining
on the right would it actually benefit
the left if he actually just stayed I
think that the way in which so here's
the thing
if George Anthony devolder Santos the
third junior senior stays I think the
way that it's useful to the left is that
they can continue to make it a story
that this guy has been allowed to stay
by the Republican party and show how low
their standards are and all these
different things the trick to it is they
have to keep it in the news and they
have to constantly find new lies and
things to talk about because otherwise
it'll just sort of Fade Away you're not
going to get two years out of this
unless you can keep finding new lies
yeah I'm just curious to see where it
all leads up to that's all we can do see
what happens
but honestly it would be correct for him
to be forced to resign that would be the
right thing absolutely yeah yeah I just
wanted to make that disclaimer so 100
yeah thanks for taking my call that was
my first time using a Discord call I'm
glad it didn't go too bad no you did
relatively well after we sorted out that
grid yeah all right thank you Joe from
Massachusetts great to have you on
all right take care all right there goes
Joe very very powerful declarations made
there let's go next to gets from Alberta
is that Alberta Canada gets
yes that is well welcome
oh man huge fan of the show
um just curious if you've ever seen the
documentary the territory on Disney plus
no I have not what is it
oh it's just an environmental
um that's what indigenous peoples
uh I'm a little nervous you're doing
good people in the Amazon and they're
fighting
um the expansion of this basically
industrial colonization
interesting fantastic watched if you
haven't seen it
um the only ask that I have of your your
show is that it'd be kind of cool if you
had some indigenous speakers talking on
indigenous issues
indigenous to wear
uh if it's a North American issue then
grabbing someone from the local nation
that could talk about that
um I know that with sodens right now are
always in a state of Perpetual
um battle with the oil companies and the
RCMP and they're they have activists
they have land Defenders that would you
know love to talk and spread their
message and raise awareness I think
that's a very interesting idea we will
look into it immediately
yeah that's that I love the show I just
be awesome to see more uh brown and
black people uh specifically people from
those Nations and that's the only ask I
have I think you're amazing
um your debate I don't think was a
debacle it was really weird watching
some guy play 40 chess with himself you
mean the Patrick that David one are you
talking about pbd yeah it was it was
interesting to watch somebody beat
themselves in 4D chess and you're just
sitting back and watching like what are
you talking about there were so many
dimensions that they were playing
against themselves essentially
that was great so that's all I got to
say just to be nice to see more
indigenous folks if you need to hook up
I can send some like uh Representatives
if you want a contact information too
all right gets from Alberta I appreciate
the suggestion thank you
ciao all right there he goes gets great
to have him on one of our sponsors is
paired the app for couples every day
paired gives you and your partner
questions quizzes games to have fun to
stay connected to deepen your
conversations and get to know each other
better what's great about it is you
don't even have to be in the same room
especially with the baby right now my
girlfriend and I are quite busy and
paired really helped us to stay
connected you get a daily question to
answer you can't see your partner's
answer until you answer yourself and
their questions about everything
relationship life intimacy other things
and all of the exercises were developed
by academic psychologists and expert
relationship therapists as well
questions like what makes you feel lucky
in your relationship great when you want
to remember and have gratitude a really
great thing what's an activity you could
try together this month actually gets
people thinking about things to do it
can go in really funny directions as
well but it just always feels like time
well spent head over to paired.com
Pacman for a seven day free trial and 25
off a subscription the link is down
below